we're gonna begin with what you need to
know and there is news and Kansas City
tyree killed the Chiefs receiver has
been in kind of an unofficial suspended
status remember on the first evening of
the draft that chilling audio came out a
couple of hours later the Chiefs reached
a mutual agreement with Hill that he
would stay away from offseason workouts
he's been away from offseason workouts
he never returned before the conclusion
of the off season program now multiple
reports indicate that Hill will be
meeting with NFL investigators this week
and parsing the various reports together
Chris it comes out like this Wednesday
is the first one multiple interviews set
which could track the reality that there
are multiple potential violations of the
personal conduct policy the league is
looking into and I think the league
would like to move this along because
training camp is gonna be here in less
than a month they need to start making
some decisions about what Tyree kills
status is going to be when the 2019
regular season rolls around yeah well
it's good to see that you know that
we're getting somewhere here and that
the NFL is finally gonna have a chance
to talk to him and dig into this you
know whole subject a little bit you know
the one thing I'm amazed by really I
mean more than anything that jumps out
to me to read this is you know what what
are the Kansas City Chiefs feel like
right now you know do they are they like
mad at the NFL to say like hey could you
guys get this going could you come to
town and investigate and hurry up
already because like you said training
camps coming
I mean Tyree kill was a huge part of
their team you know you'd like to make
adjustments and I know they've drafted
guys to maybe replace them and the Col
Hardman from Georgia in the second round
and things like that but you know I if
I'm the Kansas City Chiefs I'm a little
annoyed that the the league is drug you
know drug its feet a little here too
just so you can't really figure out what
you want to do in your roster and how
you want to frame your offensive team to
a degree well and I agree with you and
also if the NFL isn't going to make a
final decision if they're going to
continue to defer to law enforcement
proceedings in in Kansas where among
other things there's an ongoing question
of when and if Tyree kills
three-year-old child will be reunited
with he'll and it's and the child's
mother crystal espen all that as of May
it looked like the league was going to
continue to wait and wait and wait for
that procedure to
before ever talking to Hill so
something's happened to allow the NFL to
accelerate from the Chiefs perspective
if he ends up on the commissioner exempt
list they end up paying him to not play
football right I mean if he's not gonna
play at some level it's fair for them to
say we don't want to pay him to not play
so I think that the wheels are now in
motion for what would be a potential
suspension as of week one of the regular
season he'd be eligible presumably to be
with the team for training camp in the
preseason any suspension would begin
upon the conclusion of the fourth
preseason game and you know Chris
there's a lot of people out there
specifically Chiefs fans who have
themselves convinced that the only way
he can be suspended is if there's
sufficient proof that he in some way
injured his three-year-old child and and
I've studied the personal conduct policy
you can be suspended for making threats
and you can interpret that audio tape
that we first heard in late April as
containing a threat against a woman that
he admitted to having choked and beaten
while she was pregnant in December of
2014 and also there's language in the
personal conduct policy that could be
applied to Hill as it relates to
whatever circumstances in the household
resulted in the child being removed from
his custody that is a major deal when
the state intervenes and interferes with
the relationship between parent and
child it takes a lot to get that to
happen so whatever was going on in the
household that caused the government to
come in and take that child away could
be grounds for a separate violation of
the personal conduct policy and hovering
over all this is what I mentioned a
minute ago right the fact that he's
previously engaged in heinous violence
against Crystal Hospital and has never
suffered an NFL consequence for it other
than following around five of the draft
never suspended by the NFL for it that's
gonna influence what the NFL does with
him so that there's a stew of factors
here that I think leads to a suspension
the question Chris is how long will the
suspension be that's something that
we'll find out between now and
presumably the start of the regular see
yeah that's what I'm gonna be interested
to see I mean I you know again you know
this is not a good look we know that I
mean I just I don't know what to believe
in the whole the whole story at this
point you know whether it's Hill espen
all it's both what
ever you know IIIi don't know where the
story is exactly I really don't all I
know is it's a really bad look for tie
read kill and certainly wasn't doing the
best job you know being a father and
being a good husband but Mike something
you brought up too that just jumps out
to me about the commissioner exempt list
you know and having to pay him and all
that to maybe that's what the NFL does
going far further you know going you
know you want to draft a guy that's got
some red flags by them and the you know
coming out in the NFL Draft okay but if
something happens maybe you need to
maybe that needs to be something going
on going forward you're on the hook for
paying them if he gets in trouble again
or something like that why do you want
to reward the guy wait a minute wouldn't
tell maybe some way you find I'm just
saying maybe this may be one way there's
one way right create a disincentive yeah
take chances on guys that you shouldn't
take chances on because that's the right
way take draft pick you got to come up
with a formula that takes away future
draft picks because the Chiefs looked at
this when they draft the Tyree kill hey
it's a fifth round pick and you know
what if he never plays another down for
the Chiefs it was a good investment of a
fifth round pick
sure great they'd surely like to have
him for seven more years yeah but if he
never plays again hey risk reward they
we won right we had a great player for
three years that's right and you don't
want the analysis to go that way just
like Richie incognito with the Raiders
you don't want the analysis to be out
what the hell it's a minimum value
contract if he if he does something that
he shouldn't do we just cut him there
should be a greater consequence when you
roll the dice on a guy that has made who
he is that's where I was going your ID
anyone who's pay attention yeah your
idea is better than mine that's what I
was trying to say about the team hey
that's not that shocking go ahead you
jerk
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports